what are your thoughts on uh this Kanye
last couple of weeks with uh just
there's so much to um in the last couple
of weeks is not something that surprised
me obviously I mean that's yay
um but I think sometimes you have to
also realize that everybody's not like
him or think like him right so you can't
force your opinions on other people
there's a lot of history that goes with
black and whites in America and there's
so much more that he needs to you know
desensitize himself from and realize
that there's certain things that may not
have affected you but has affected other
people because real lives were lost in
the process of these actions right so
you can't just say White lives matter in
the case like that specifically of
course everyone knows that all lives
matter but there's a specific history in
Africa I mean America that just needs to
be recognized and acknowledged because
of the history of black people in this
country that's all it is yeah I think
that it's to the point where it's like
we all recognize that black lives matter
is a true statement right we also can
recognize that the organization might
not have did the best business right but
we also have to recognize that the term
White lives matter is a term that racist
people use right like the roots right
but to be said it's also a true term if
you say it out loud factually yes
everyone's lives matter but at the same
time black lives matter became a slogan
because it was obvious that black lives
did not matter as much as everyone
else's right right absolutely and
historically in America if we're being
honest right I mean listen historically
everywhere man no for sure you know what
I mean the colonization of parts of your
home country yeah I was gonna say in
your home country yeah I heard in Africa
it's still bad in some places well it's
Africa's kind of changing
I don't know if that's for the good
but in certain parts in Africa white
people are in the projects wow and the
black people are in The Mansions they
just stayed that way I mean listen man
so it depends on what size what part of
Africa is that I mean oh that's from
South Africa okay yeah South Africa the
white people now are screaming for
equality
which is crazy right pretty crazy it's
like you guys colonize you guys
colonized South Africa right yeah yeah
the UK is calling you yeah the UK is
like hold up now but there's nothing
they could do because they never left
the UK they just they they literally
claimed it from the UK it started
selling off land that they never even
owned right because they had the weapons
obviously they all powered people but as
the uprising since everything came they
the Revolt happened and people start
fighting back yeah I think a lot of
things with the Kanye think people are
like a little shook up about is I saw I
don't know if you saw Maverick Carter
just said that he's uh they he came and
recorded an episode of LeBron show the
shop which is a HBO show right and they
decided not to release it because he was
I guess saying some wild [ __ ] right
Samantha anti-semitic [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying but you probably have a
better insight to yay than most people
considering how close in proximity your
brother worked for for people who don't
know your brother management for some
time right yeah he managed him for some
time he's not currently managing him now
but he does I don't know if anybody can
manage Kanye well Kanye is unmanageable
because he pretty much managed himself
right all you can do is put barricades
to help him protect him yeah that's the
only way that's the only job of a
manager around yay is to protect him
from himself I was going to say would
you can because I think some people
don't they don't know him like everyone
else does would you say he's like a
generally a good dude no genuinely he's
a really good dude good heart great
intentions
um I just think that
he's in a position where he believes
that his opinion matters in the world
and when you do that and people telling
you well you don't your opinion don't
matter in my life yeah and you're
forcing your opinion to matter in their
life but not getting all the details of
why his opinion don't matter in your
life it can create an issue when you're
too confident
um you know yeah and if you're like so
sure that you're right and everyone else
is wrong exactly it's like that
eliminates any Nuance or discussion to
be had about any particular issue
because you're saying it's my way
because I'm Connie and I'm a [ __ ]
genius because you know without taking
anything from yay he's been through a
whole spiritual journey yeah so he's
seen things that the average man didn't
see like I honestly believe that he's
went through spiritually uh a journey
that average people don't go yeah he
really did but the thing is when you
believe that people understand you the
way you understand you that's a that's
where it becomes an issue yeah because
not everybody understands his position
and when you're trying to so hard to
explain it to people who will never get
it because they have to go through your
journey to get it it becomes an uphill
battle trying to you know and people
have to give you the benefit of the
doubt that you're what you're saying
isn't what you're saying that you have a
bigger message behind it and when you
say certain [ __ ] that he says recently
it's like I don't really care what your
thought process was right right and
you're and you don't care enough really
explain it right exactly so that's when
that's when everyone takes it personal
and then when it goes personal then it's
hard to talk about